[Música]
vamos a empezar pues estas pequeñas
frases si estamos en un colegio
americano antes el inglés aquí es
increíble pero nada más para traducir en
su mente los osos perezosos son babosos
y engorrosos como lo traduciría
por ejemplo la frase tienes unas rachas
de fachas bien chafas todas estas me las
invento yo no las ejército pero si se
fijan tienen muchos regionalismos como
traducimos fachas cómo traducimos chafas
como traducimos reyes está padre su
si su patrón
y este es
la infraestructura es insultante e
inaceptable a lo mejor esto lo han
escuchado en muchos políticos de ahora
no les han excepto en shopping en él
aceptó justifican aunque muchos sabemos
inglés y ustedes tienen un nivel
superior de inglés pero gran parte de
las personas estas frases se ven como
muy complicadas no que es eslava es
engorroso como que hay muchas palabras
que no son tan naturales para nosotros y
eso pasa en el inglés y pasa imágenes en
todos los demás idiomas y lecciones le
despidiera ahora traduzcamos la francés
o el ruso sería muy complicado que
hables muy bien incluso chino o lo que
sea pero si no se lo saben no pasa nada
hay mucha gente que está a niveles altos
que el inglés tampoco se les da
tengo que sepan su inglés no está tan
mal
hace dos años empezamos una empresa unos
amigos y yo con este dispositivo que
venía un poco las personas que lo
compraban lo comparaban con el bar ball
face y nosotros llamamos el pay lot pero
dale fischer una pieza de la ciencia
ficción en el hacker sacasa galaxy que
era pescadito que te ponías en el oído y
podías traducirlo en distintos idiomas
lanzamos la campaña este ya es el
producto final
la segunda campaña en indiegogo y nos
fue mejor de lo que esperábamos el
primer día los primeros dos días venimos
más de un millón de dólares en pedidos y
después cerramos con 30.000 unidades
cuando acabó la campaña en indiegogo y
yo ya mandamos a 148 países y estando
trabajando con la segunda edición de del
producto nuevas mejoras etcétera pero a
mí me entusiasmaba mucho digo aparte que
era nuestro proyecto y como nuestro bebé
y está súper padre ver tu diseño hecho
en 330 mil unidades 40 mil unidades
porque nuestra misión de la empresa
siempre fue destruir las barreras del
lenguaje
y bueno ahora les voy a contar un poco
de lo que yo siento que va a ser el
futuro de la comunicación global eso
está padre a quien nosotros practicamos
pero más bien cree llevan compartirles
mi visión de lo que creo que va a ser a
lo mejor dentro de tres años o dos años
a partir de ahora
y una de las cosas que yo tengo por
seguro es que todos vamos a hablar en
inglés
sí sí los idiomas fueran comida mexicana
el inglés son las quesadillas es decir
eso es un idioma muy simple muy sencillo
el español a lo mejor es un chile
relleno no a unos chiles en nogada así
ya con la cremita encima de la granada
entonces se fijan eso es una super
ventaja que tenemos porque ya dominan el
chile en nogada pasar y de quesadillas a
casa y hacer la quesadilla de taco bell
que es una ofensa a la comida y en la
quesadilla del mercado oaxaca con flor
de cempasúchil vitagénesis hay de que
sabías que esa dieuzaide inglesa inglés
pero parte de eso se lo debemos a los
vikingos cuando ellos invadieron
inglaterra llegaron y vieron que los
locales usaban plurales como demasiado
raros no sea más es más porque los chips
chip porque como que no les entendía y
en el lenguaje vikingo ellos usaban la s
para referirse al plural
que si explican es lo que usamos ahora
todos entonces los vikingos ayudaron
mucho a simplificar el inglés otra cosa
que lo hizo muy fácil es que los
británicos eran demasiado elegantes y
sólo tenían el modo formal si se fijan
nosotros tenemos como tú y usted y eso
se repite en francés en china en chino
tienen está bien
más entonces en inglés y creo que no
solo nos quedamos con el formal y por
eso sólo tenemos el el you
la otra cosa es que no tiene género
nosotros tenemos como el sol la luna en
alemán es al revés
la luna es masculino el sol es femenino
y en tres tienes que aprenderte esta
cosa es hombre o es mujer en la
televisión el agua es hombre o mujer
porque es el es como el azúcar tienes
como esas detalles y la otra es que
tenemos acentos en el español ya saben
los sesentas tácitos todos los errores
ortografía que teníamos en los exámenes
y hay lenguajes como el chino que tiene
cuatro acentos no entonces cualquiera
que ha intentado aprender chino sabe que
eso es una tortura no en inglés no
tenemos ninguna otra ventaja el inglés
es que cada año se agregan mil palabras
entonces un lenguaje muy flexible la
mitad de esas palabras vienen de otro
idioma entonces también es un lenguaje
muy susceptible a la mezcla y tiene una
lógica muy simple
se mezclan palabras muy fáciles a veces
en español nos complicamos te quiero te
amo me amas hacer como que tenemos
muchos detalles en dos muchos matices
dos terceras partes del mundo hablan 12
idiomas
obviamente el chino es de los que está
teniendo mucho más crecimiento y cada
año van a ir desapareciendo los idiomas
y eso puede ser un triste hoy tenemos
6.000 idiomas y se calcula que en 100
años solo vamos a tener 600 idiomas
existiendo en el mundo pero no es tan
triste en el sentido que nos vamos a
poder comunicar mejor entre los idiomas
que quedan nos vamos a ir pudiendo
entender más
la otra cosa que creo que vamos que va a
crecer muchísimo es la ayuda que tenemos
y la ayuda de bots la ayuda de
computadoras y de inteligencia
artificial
ya lo usamos hoy en el día a día como
decía en cada vez que piden un número
cada vez que en el google maps calcula
en la ruta cada vez que ustedes hablan
con sirio con cualquier asistente que no
que transforme sus rollitos raros que
salen de su boca y los transforma en
texto y después en un input válido para
la computadora pero cada vez se va a
permear más otra de las cosas que vamos
a tener es que vamos a poder escuchar
mejor hay dos tecnologías un eczema de
xavi station y la otra es activar box
capturing junto con visión de
computadora que les permite a las
computadoras escuchar mucho mejor a mí
me impresiona en varios de los audios
que tenemos yo siendo un humano normal
que no no entiendo lo que está pasando
en el en el audio o sea como que es
demasiado el ruido para mí y las
computadoras lo filtran perfecto
entonces el hecho de una computadora
puede escuchar mejor que yo me permite
mucho más en explico a la mujer a veces
estás sabes en el antro y le preguntas
cómo estás casadas y me gusta la carne
asada como que hay mucha confusión
entonces en los términos de
en lugares donde hay mucho ruido
restaurantes etc
está mejor este es un vídeo que tiene me
ayudan con el audio nada más
entonces se fijan tenemos dos personas
gritando al mismo tiempo haciendo stand
up comedy y la computadora puede filtrar
perfecto quien está hablando cuando tú
le dices no como a ver escucha este
chavo de que mejor escuche este show de
que si fijan el nivel de ruido conflicto
que hay ahí es mucho existe uno como
humano intenta escuchar lo que está
diciendo cada uno es súper confuso este
es una mezcla entre
campo de visión y la parte de richter y
6 en la otra es que vamos a poder
entender mejor una de las tecnologías
estamos desarrollando es utilizando más
sender ning poder detectar el lenguaje
automáticamente hoy en día tienes que
meterte en esta aplicación y decirle
como yo quiero hablar francés y que se
traduzca ruso pero si la computadora
puede sólo estar escuchando decir como a
eso me suena como ruso solito podría ser
la traducción incluso si estás entre 5 6
7 personas distintas pueden entender
mejor y también una de más es la parte
del idioma sino el dialecto que tienen a
veces como ese es un español como más
guatemalteco me suena como más un
español chileno
el poder entrenar a las computadoras con
miles y miles y miles de horas nos va a
permitir hacer toda la toda la parte de
traducción mucho más invisible mucho más
simultánea
y bueno y la otra es que las
computadoras entienden el contexto
tienen que a lo mejor vas a estar en un
hospital es distinto el negocio el
lenguaje que van a estar así estás en un
restaurante o lo que sea
el siguiente vídeo que les voy a mostrar
es
habla un poquito de eso de hecho en la
mañana estábamos hablando de hablando de
eso
otra de las tecnologías que
que está afuera y que se va a combinar
junto con el contexto es la parte del
país macri voice micro y es básicamente
duplicar tu voz es sobre todo es una
tecnología que está desarrollando baidu
y varias compañías chinas en donde tú le
hablas según ellos durante cinco minutos
según yo durante mucho más pero ellos
pueden después duplicar tu voz y
entonces imagina que tú jamás has
hablado japonés en tu vida pero todo lo
que tú estés diciendo en español se va a
traducir a japonés con tu voz y eso nos
permite tener como una traducción mucho
más natural mucho más mágica digamos de
alguna forma no tenemos en la parte del
neuro balls voice cloud y también la
parte de camps concatenar chef
síntesis que eso es básicamente que las
computadoras hablen mucho más humano
mucho mucho más humanos y se cuidan de
los primeros gps en 200 metros da vuelta
a la derecha era como viste es súper
robótico no de hecho estuve buscando me
ayuden a poner este clip de audio
gris
hola gracias por venir a esta plática
espero que todo el mundo crea que esta
voz es de una persona real y no es
generada por computadora miraría me los
otros monterrey digan que esta voz se
escucha robótica ji ji ja ja ja
estoy buscando estos viejos de jazz y
antes sonaba todo todo todo el tenemos
estas voces que ven como horriblemente
robóticas
hola gracias por venir ya está y ahora
tenemos este tipo de este vídeo lo mejor
ya lo han visto que es justo en un
sistema de asistente que cumple c's que
hace una llamada por teléfono para pedir
una cita de para cortarse el cabello
harker appointment aunque usted ve que
no hubo energía
igual
paraguay capi m
asociar medidas de presión
social
efe
si se fijan el nivel de naturalidad que
tiene la voz y el hecho que comprende el
contexto que sepa que le están
preguntando no tenemos este servicio
hasta ahora pero podemos tener esta duda
el nivel de inteligencia que tienen se
vuelve muy avanzado y si lo pensamos
bien esto nos permite multiplicar nos de
tu lista de google como hoy es más bien
una cita pero ya oa lo mejor si está
haciendo una traducción llegas un hotel
en japón y tú dices como nada más de un
cuarto y entonces tú ples puede estar
hablando tu clon puede estar hablando
con el restaurante con el hotel y es
como oye no tenemos pagar con tarjeta es
que no tengo tarjeta bueno salgo en
efectivo y tú tú no estás pone atención
nada más te enteras del resultado
entonces eso nos permite a nosotros
multiplicarnos y poder hacer varias
cosas al mismo tiempo aquí no se ve
fácil pero es la misma persona
y la otra es que vamos a poder traducir
el lenguaje no verbal significan a veces
es como siempre decimos lo que queremos
decir así es cómo estás enojada
no descarga de computadores y como no
está enojada pero cuando puedes tener
acelerómetros dentro de tu cabeza cuando
puedes estar moviendo de cuando puedes
tener visión pues no nada más traducirlo
verbal sino toda la parte del lenguaje
no verbal que compone gran parte de lo
que nosotros utilizamos para
comunicarnos entonces digo esto es una
tecnología que también estamos
trabajando con eso pero el puro hecho de
poder tener las expresiones que tú estás
usando con la cabeza es una parte del
contexto que le das para implementar la
asertividad de la traducción
las otras que vamos a poder ser más
sexys ahora y varios sistemas y de hecho
google también está implementando un
además puede clonar tu voz pero también
puede sonar la voz de garabato de éste
es cardio hanson o de cualquier actor
que no sé capitán américa o quien sea
que les gusten entonces es como está
padre también poder hablar como ellos y
poder comunicarte con ellos y poder
tener toda esta parte de clonar la voz
de quien sea hay unas implicaciones que
a lo mejor pueden ser un poquito
negativas a lo mejor puedes clonar la
voz de donald trump o de anv lo tiene
puede tener usos no tan intencionados
y la otra es que vamos a poder escribir
mejor hay varias empresas que también
están lanzando sus ipads para eso tanto
el google cloud speech text que acaba de
lanzar pero ahora cuando nosotros
hablamos no tiene la puntuación la coma
la situación correcta y con las nuevas
herramientas es perfecto perfecto de
veces que tú ministro hoy no sé cómo
pondría como punto y coma aquí y como
apuntó y ellos lo hacen de una manera
perfecta ya nosotros nos sirve muchísimo
porque esa traducción teniendo bien
hecha la puntuación nos da mucha más
asertividad cuando traducimos a otro
idioma
y la otra que a mí me emociona mucho es
que creo que vamos a evitar conflictos y
comprendernos mejor el señor de la foto
es nikita khrushchev que en 1956 estaba
en la embajada de polonia en rusia tenía
dos embajadores
y éste estaban ahí platicando y él les
dijo algo así como si se escuchó
muy redes para dejarlo bien seguro lo
está diciendo mal pero eso lo tradujo su
traductor
personal a los vamos a enterrar y
y estaban justo en medio de la guerra
fría y cuando el líder ruso dice los
vamos a enterrar lo traducen los
embajadores salen y según varios
historiadores eso tomo todo el progreso
que se había hecho entre ambas naciones
diez años atrás en la historia entonces
cuando cuando aquí está cristiano se
enteró de todo ese efecto que pasó en lo
que había querido decir es como nosotros
vamos a durar más que ustedes y los
vamos a ver como el que el comunismo
dura más que el capitalismo ustedes van
a morir antes que nosotros sigue siendo
un poquito rudo pero no es lo mismo que
los vamos a matar sondeando si era todo
no es un tema y eso después de que fue
una crisis etcétera
y también incluso pasó la semana pasada
en nueva york' no sé si supieron de este
abogado ahora no sé qué que se puso a
gritarle a tres empleados que hablaban
español y desde manhattan y jap speak
english que los latinos son muy buenos
para organizarse y al día siguiente
había una fiesta en frente de su
departamento con mariachis cambiaron su
negocio a un restaurante mexicano le
sacaron eso es también estuvo padre pero
estos conflictos significan son sólo por
no entendernos no comprendernos y siento
yo que cuando podamos tener realmente
esa comprensión lo vamos a evitar muchos
de los conflictos que tenemos ahora pero
también desarrollar más empatía a veces
cuando alguien no habla tu idioma como
que tiene esa isla ppdeg
y van a ser un árbol justo la guerra es
lo que pasa con del lenguaje falla
me entusiasma porque también hay muchas
empresas gigantes que están entrando a
este sector nosotros tuvimos la suerte
que cuando lanzamos nuestro producto al
año siguiente google lanzó una solución
muy similar los grupos pixel bots pero
por obra divina nosotros
éramos mejores que personas salir varios
vídeos en youtube comparando el pay la
'contra' que pixar al box y como ganamos
la gente con este producto es una
maravilla porque google es google
siendo yo que el producto google no
estaba tan bien desarrollado pero ese es
un punto de la tecnología muy
emocionante donde todas estas personas
están saltando en un justo facebook que
acaba también de abrir su network para
network para que todas las personas que
hagan entrenamientos allí pensante y
baidu que son dos gigantes chinos en es
difícil imaginarse el tamaño estas
empresas
también están entrando al mercado de
hecho por alguna razón para las
computadoras es más fácil entender chino
que inglés o español o cualquier otro
idioma porque como lo han estado
entrenando durante varias décadas y como
son un montón las computadoras entienden
mucho más natural el chino que cualquier
otro idioma
entonces siento yo que el crecimiento va
a ser acelerado y a mí me emociona en
general como mexicano porque yo estoy
convencido que nosotros venimos como de
una tribu nómada no nos encanta movernos
y nos encanta el mundo y nos encanta
cambiar y nos encanta conocer todos
lados y eso sumado a que casi nada nos
da miedo andamos por todos lados el
mexicanos mexicano es una persona muy
aventado muy hambrienta del mundo no
somos un poco como estos estarán malas
que estén corriendo por todos lados y
dominando dominando la competencia
y si gran parte a mí que me motiva en
general es que siento que todos
necesitamos un poquito de todos los
demás necesitábamos de entender más a
las personas de marruecos y necesitamos
un poquito más de qatar
necesitamos más de korea y necesitamos
poder entender realmente todo el planeta
porque no estamos perdiendo un montón
cuanto no nos hemos perdido por no
hablar árabe cuanto no nos hemos perdido
por simplemente no poder entender sus
estructuras sociales porque nuestro ruso
es chafísima y no podemos entender sus
artes y sus culturas o poder ir a japón
y tener una conversación padrísima sobre
la vida
entonces creo que eso es lo que me
emociona y ella siente que el futuro va
a ser mucho más universal
[Música]
sí
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]